يوجد expedia أولاً
فتح هذا الرجل في فلوريدا صندوقًا تم تسليمه بواسطة Fedex
ثم كان داخل الصندوق حقيبة
وداخل الحقيبة الزرقاء كانت
اليد وذهلتني باعتبارها واحدة
من أغرب الأشياء التي تلقيتها على الإطلاق ،
هل قال واحدة  من أغرب الأشياء
لأنه
سرعان ما حصل على واحدة ثانية ، فهذه
هي الأيدي
لا لا لا شيء ، فقط يدان اليمنى
مرقمتان بوضوح من إصدار محدود
من 550 ، لم يتطلب الأمر الكثير من البحث على
googling لكي يكتشف شون أوفاريل يده.
عقد
لديّ يد مطبوعة ثلاثية الأبعاد ،
دخل جو جوناس من الإخوة جوناس
[موسيقى]
جو في شراكة مع expedia لتقديم
شعار الشركة التسويقي.
كان
توقيع جو يدين سبورتس الذي صنعوه من
مشجعين من البلاستيك الصلب يتقدمون بطلب للحصول على فرصة للفوز
بإحدى العروض التي
تشير إلى أن أحد معارفه يجب أن
يكون قد خدع شون من
خلال التقدم له ولكن شون يقول لا
أحد يشعر  لقد
قال مازحًا ، أنا سعيد لأنه لم يكن
رأس حصان
كما تعلم في الأب الروحي ،
لكن شون واجه مشكلة تلخصها هدية
نقلاً عن تالاديجا نايتس ، لست متأكدًا
مما يجب أن أفعله بيدي
قدم شون يدي جو  إلى ابنته المعجبة بشقيقه جوناس
وزوجة ابنه ولكن لا يوجد
عدد قليل من الأشخاص يبيعون على موقع ئي باي مقابل حوالي 150
إلى
300 دولار تقريبًا ، لكن شون لا يشعر بأنه محق في
تحقيق ربح يخطط لمنح
يديه إلى الأخوة جوناس
المعجبين الفائقين  قد لا تكون الأيدي
متعددة الاستخدامات مثل
شيء من عائلة آدامز ، فلماذا نشكرك على
أن الشيء الأبيض
أعلى قليلاً وأه إلى الشيء الصحيح
الذي يمكنك استخدامه تمامًا
كجني خدش ظهر معظم
[موسيقى]
cnn نيويورك